[inaudible].
I think the national media coverage of
Venezuela increases.
It seems as if they're national media
coverage of their own country is
actually decreasing.
At the time we were preparing this
video,
we had a look at the website of Telesur,
one of their largest state owned
television networks.
On the main page there,
29 headlines and just six of them were
talking about their own country.
Despite what this looks like on the face
of things though,
this couldn't actually resemble any
better what is actually happening in
Venezuela
[inaudible]
there is no one who denies that the
South American country is going through
one of the worst humanitarian crises
that the entire continent has ever seen.
According to a study run by three
universities from this country,
the average Venezuelan ways between nine
and 10 kilos less than two years ago
when the food shortages began.
Now the big question is how much blame
should be apportioned to the Venezuelan
President Nicolas Maduro?
This is where people have rather
difference opinion.
Too many political analysts,
Venezuela is not a democratic nation
anymore.
Things like the president's attempt to
dissolve the parliament or jailing
politicians from the opposition have
triggered the diplomatic crises at the
highest level in at Adidas retires their
ambassador in Venezuela with the support
of their parliament.
Nonetheless,
there are others who still play in
Venezuela is a democracy.
They even seen Nicolas Maduro.
The president's is defending himself
from acute to tar.
So the question is here,
who is right?
Can we say the Venezuela is a
dictatorship or is there's something of
an exaggeration they,
we're going to answer this question,
but before we do,
let's check out the story of Nicolas
Maduro.
Bent is government
is preparing a coup d'etat according to
Madurai.
The Venezuelan crisis can be summarized
as a conspiracy by the United States and
that allies to destroy the Bolivarian
Revolution and the so called 21st
century socialism,
they elite Imperioli,
purest elite despises our people and
have the goal of destroying our
lifestyle,
our democracy,
our independence,
and our homeland.
They have decided to trigger plans to
destabilize the Venezuelan society.
Oh yeah,
so there's an La,
I know you're probably thinking,
but let's just imagine for a quick
amendment that that theory actually make
some kind of sense.
In this case,
the imperialists delete.
I'll not only trying to dismantle the
Venezuelan economy,
but also their governments,
and this is what explains Nicolas Maduro
is fear of a coop.
But hold on for just a moment because
before we continue,
we should explain what acu actually
means.
Well,
Acute Atar is defined as the taking of
power in a sudden and violent action
carried out by a powerful group like the
army.
And surprise,
surprise,
the Venezuelan army is absolutely loyal
to Nicolas Maduro.
Father of the Bolivarian Revolution,
Hugo Chavez used to be a member of the
military.
Unlike other countries like the UK where
it is forbidden by law for soldiers to
run for office in Venezuela,
there are several ministers that come
from the armed forces air.
We have left tenants,
Melendez,
revise the president's chief of staff or
the General Marco Reavers,
the Minister of foods.
Actually one third of Maduro has
governments comes from the military.
This
being said,
who could successfully conduct a coup in
Venezuela according to moderate?
Well,
as the amount of gas do you suggest is
this would be his political opponents.
There's only one problem with this
theory though.
Not one of them has any relationship
whatsoever with the military.
Yeah.
People like on Enrique Katrina's or
Leopoldo Lopez or any of the other
opposition leaders are professional
politicians or former businessmen and
they have no military group supporting
them.
Despite all of this,
the government keeps saying that all
these politicians,
all the real instigators of the country,
street violence and live in a country
where people need a full day's wages to
get a bag of onions.
It's absolutely normal that people would
want to organize demonstrations.
Oh,
and to add to this,
the fact that Caracas is the most
violent city in all of Latin America,
and as you'll probably understand why
most of the protests send up like that.
Yeah.
Nonetheless,
according to the government of
Venezuela,
the clashes between the police and the
protestors are nothing but the outcome
of bourgeoisie propaganda.
This is why in September of 2015 three
months before having parliamentary
elections,
the Venezuelan police arrested Leopoldo
Lopez,
one of the opposition leaders.
The prosecutor claims that this man was
inciting people into violence with these
kinds of statements made on
what's that
guts to take me to prison?
Are you waiting for orders from Havana?
I'm telling you the truth is on our
side,
but
the turning points would come later in
December of 2015 at this time at
Venezuela has parliamentary elections,
and as you can imagine that the
opposition party is unified in the so
called Table of Democratic Unity,
Aka the mud beats him do a rose party by
over 2 million votes.
The president's reaction was actually
what you'd expect from every democratic
leader.
Recognize this outcome.
Even if we don't like it,
we accept it and we say that democracy
and the constitution or the real winners
here,
hold on for just a moment because this
is when the problem starts.
This brands,
new nt government parliament started
trying to impeach the president and this
is where all of a sudden,
but during and his ministers made a
radical shift.
Economic war has influenced a big share
of our population and this turned the
public opinion.
During this time,
Nicolas and the dirt road tried to
dissolve parliament according to his
government.
Some of those mps had been elected by
cheating in the electoral process and
not even the supreme court in Venezuela
excepted this version.
This is why on May the first 2017 maduro
made his final decision draw,
calling up the constitutional power to
get the piece.
This republic needs to beat the fascist
coup and let the people bring the
harmony and the actual national
dialogue.
And otherwise my delray wants a new
parliament and writing brands new
constitution,
which would give him unlimited power and
this would be the ultimate step for
creating a dictatorship.
And does he might.
Well now one's Ed.
Is this going to be through an election?
Well,
theoretically,
yes,
but the truth is that since 2015 there
are lots of opposition leaders behind
bars.
And so,
well,
what about the media?
Badori supporters say that Venezuela has
freedom of speech,
but is this really true?
Well,
let's have a look at that.
Their freedom of speech in Venezuela,
according to the Curran's Venezuelan
constitution,
freedom of speech is a fundamental
right.
And yes,
there are many newspapers who opposed
then you've governments.
But guess what the problem these
newspapers have is,
well they don't actually have any paper
on which to print their new
just like that in Venezuela paper is a
monopoly regulated by the state.
And this is why gay media outlets like
El now cnl,
which is contrary to Maduro,
has to reduce their circulation.
And even the number of pages in their
newspaper other day lease of had to
become weeklies because they couldn't
print so many papers.
And now you might be wondering,
well what about the incident?
I mean who even reads print papers
anymore?
Well,
unfortunately maduro and is governments
have absolute power to block any
website.
Have you ever heard of the site?
Basically this is a site where you could
put the link for any page and it makes
it shorter.
So you can tweet it easily.
Does it sound counterrevolution reading?
Well,
check this out.
Leave shortcuts are banned in Venezuela.
As you can imagine,
if Britney is forbid,
an other critical websites like CNN
dollars a day or info bae up or say
bands.
If you live in Venezuela and you want to
visit these websites,
you must do it through a proxy.
Just like in China.
And of course,
don't forget that there have been more
than 40 journalists threatened by the
government's allies or even worse,
six
twitter users are in jail in Venezuela
for giving their political opinions.
Yup.
Yeah,
that rights they on knots being judged
or fines.
They are in prison.
But hold on for just minute because all
of this is nothing compared to what's
happening in television.
And you got to call me for decades.
Caracas was the Hollywood of South
American soap operas.
Venezuela was famous for having lots of
private TV stations.
And of course some of them were contrary
to Madurai as governments.
The Venezuelan Constitution provides for
freedom of speech on tv,
but on the other hands,
the law of forces them to broadcast all
of the president's speeches and we're
not talking about one show a year.
Maduro appears on TV several times a
week and the TVS have to make a break
matter their schedule and broadcast the
presidential speech.
Sometimes these speeches can last for
hours and add to this other stories like
this one.
No bovie Xian,
a Venezuelan TV broadcaster is sold to a
new owner who promises a new,
more moderate ideology.
Before medallia was the president's
during the times of Hugo Chavez glade,
the vision was a diehard antigovernment
TV station,
but all of a sudden it was sold in 2013
in the new owners had close ties with
the presidents.
So the first thing they did when they
took control of the company,
it was to fire half of the staff and
then no surprise,
surprise and global vision became a
centrist
station
making a mistake.
This is merely one example.
Today there is almost no media in
Venezuela that is critical of the
government.
So the question I would now like to ask
you is this,
what exactly is the difference between
Nicolas Maduro and any other dictator?
Can anybody claim Venezuela is still
really a democracy?
Well,
we'd love to know what you think,
Angie,
you can let us know in the comment
section below.
Meanwhile,
you should definitely check out this
video we made talking all about how the
crisis in Venezuela got started.
Don't forget to visit our friends from
the reconsidered media podcast who gave
us the voice on this video.
That is not mine.
Of course,
don't forget that we published brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday.
So hit that subscribe button below and
on the screen now and you won't miss any
video.
And then also,
if you like this video,
please do give us a thumbs up.
And as always,
I'll see you next time.
And if you'd like to hear more of my
lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider the
podcast that covers politics,
but we don't do the thinking for you
available on your favorite podcatcher.